while we've been arguing about pronouns
here in the united states and wondering
why two by fours now
cost nine dollars a piece
there's real drama unfolding in europe
tensions between ukraine and russia are
the highest they have been in a very
long time
and we get some sense that there are
political elements mostly in the
democratic party not exclusively though
who would like to see a war in europe
what is this and how concerned should we
be about it
kelsey gabbard has paid a lot of
attention to this she's a former member
of congress from the state of hawaii
we're happy to have her on tonight
congressman thanks so much for coming on
so is this conflict moving toward war
and are there leaders in this country
who would like to see that do you think
it is moving in a very dangerous
direction and the question for the
american people
is are we willing to go to war
with russia on behalf of ukraine and we
need to understand
that such a war would come at a cost
beyond anything that we can really
imagine because this is not a war that
that is just okay this is going to be
something
that's happening to someone else
somewhere else on the other side of the
world
no this is something that will directly
impact
me and you tucker every single one of
your viewers
and all of our loved ones and this is
this is a war that is not a game
it's a war in which there are no winners
because you've got
you know thousands of nuclear weapons
that the united states has aimed towards
russia
russia has thousands of nuclear weapons
aimed towards us that could hit any
town or city in america in less than 30
minutes
and exact a cost upon every one of us
that would result in excruciating death
and suffering beyond comprehension
hundreds of millions
of people dying and suffering seeing
their flesh being burned from from their
bones this is something that
that that you know you can't really even
imagine
uh and it's a cost that that we will all
pay why in the world would we ever
contemplate going to war with russia
honestly
it is one that we should not do for
those very reasons
if you look at the the impacts of what a
nuclear war
brings it really brings about the end of
the world as we know it
and our leaders should understand this
consequence
and take it seriously and this is why
president biden
instead of continuing to escalate
tensions
and continuing this new cold war between
the united states and russia
he needs to de-escalate these tensions
kind of
you know to take the heat out of it and
actually focus on bringing an end to
this new cold war because
if he doesn't then it's not a question
of
if we go to war with russia if this war
ends up
with it with a nuclear holocaust it
really is then just a question of when
and if we continue down this path that
we are on it's something that could
happen a lot sooner than any of us think
i'm just amazed by the magnitude of the
stories that all of us are missing
including those of us who are paid to
follow this stuff
and especially this story and so i
appreciate
how you so crisply and wisely
assessed that it's it's terrifying thank
you tulsi gabbard of hawaii joining us
tonight
we appreciate it thank you